les hommages continuent dans les
yvelines mardi 20 octobre à magny les
hameaux
la pluie n'a pas empêché les habitants
de venir se recueillir à l'appel de la
municipalité
ici à magny les hameaux il était
essentiel de pouvoir
se rassembler pour pouvoir montrer aussi
notre union et
face
des terroristes qui essayent de nous
diviser et surtout de de pouvoir
rappeler notre attachement à nos valeurs
de liberté d'égalité de fraternité de
laïcité
ça me paraissait important de venir pour
dire que l'école est importante en
france que les enfants ont la chance de
pouvoir y venir gratuitement et dans la
plupart du temps dans de très bonnes
conditions
[Musique]
ce mercredi à guyancourt un autre
hommage a eu lieu devant l'hôtel de
ville les habitants sont venus apporter
leur soutien à la famille de samuel pâti
des personnes se sont battus pour la
liberté la liberté d'expression est
aujourd'hui à mourir dans des conditions
telles qu'elles barbare je trouve ça
inadmissible inacceptable de confession
musulmane cette nuit en courtoise veut
éviter à tout prix les annales gagnent
j'aimerais que la société d'aujourd'hui
ne compare pas
voilà c'est important pour pour nous
adultes pour nos enfants dans l'islam on
ne tue pas au nom de dieu
c'est simple c'est un péché l'importance
du vivre ensemble c'est aussi ce qu'ont
voulu montrer les habitants de trappes
en se rassemblant pour l'hommage rendu
ce mercredi midi
ça nous a touchés et ça nous a fait mal
au coeur et on revient lui rende hommage
voilà et partager cet hommage avec les
trappistes
je pense que chacun est concerné quelles
que soient ses origines
quelle que soit sa religion même s'ils
sont athées comme moi mais je pense que
chacun doit vivre ensemble et c'est
l'essentiel sous notre république
aujourd'hui on a tendance à se dévier
sur certains éléments alors qu'en fait
on ne focalise pas sur ce qui nous
fédère et androgyne à ce qui nous fédère
est plus forte que ce qui d où peut nous
diviser n'a pas toujours tous les mêmes
opinions et la laïcité c'est aussi ça
respecter les opinions des autres
l'hommage national à samuel pâtit sera
rendu ce mercredi à partir de 19h et le
recevra la légion d'honneur à titre
posthume et sera fait commandeur des
palmes académiques